ام
[موسيقى]
ازاء الغيب تنهمر الحروف لها نظم يحس به
الشغوف
يرى فيها اصولا باسقاط
على اطرافها تبني الخطوه
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مستقره تنوع بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم الالباب وقالت يا هذا
الوقوف
يقول ابن سيرين العلم اكبر من ان يحاط به
فخذوا من كل شيء احسنه
سلام الله عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى في سوره العصر والعصر ان
الانسان لفي خسر وجاء في سوره نوح واتبعوا
من لم يزده ماله وولده الا خسارا
وفي سوره الحج نقرا ذلك هو الخسران المبين
ما الفرق بين ال خسر والخساره والخسران
يقول علماء اللغه ان الخسر هو الخساره
بشكلها المطلق مهما كان حجمها اما الخساره
فهو زياده في الخساره يعني ان يكون المرء
خاسرا اصلا ثم ياتيه الخساره فيزيده خساره
فوق خسارته
وننزل من القران ما هو شفاء ورحمه
للمؤمنين ولا يزيد الظالمين الا خسارا
فالظالمون خاسرون اصلا ثم يكون الخساره هو
زياده الخساره التي تلحق بهم واما الخسران
فهو اعلى مراتب الخسائر تجده مقترنا بال
خسارات الكبرى لا يقال عن الخساره انها
خسران الا عندما تكون كبيره
ومن الناس من يعبد الله على حرف فان اصابه
خير اطمان به وان اصابته فتنه انقلب على
وجهه خسر الدنيا والاخره ذلك هو الخسران
المبين
جاء الخسران للتعبير عن خساره الدنيا
والاخره وفي مثال اخر من سوره الزمر قل ان
الخاسرين الذين خسروا انفسهم واهليهم يوم
القيامه الا ذلك هو الخسران المبين
وهناك تلفظ الخسران مع خساره النفس والاهل
نسال الله السلامه
لاحظ عزيزي المشاهد ان الخسر هو ثلاثه
احرف اما الخسائر وهو اربعه والخسران هو
خمسه احرف فكلما زاد المبنى زاد المعنى
[موسيقى]
القوه او الخاوه يفرضها فتوات الحي او
السوق على الدكاكين لضمان عدم ايذاء
اصحابها في رزقهم ما اصل كلمه الخوف كان
شيخ القبيله في القديم يفرض على اصحاب
القافله الماره بارضه ضريبه لحمايتها فان
دفعوها انعقدت لهم مع القبيله علاقه اخوه
فلا يعتدي عليها وهي اخوه مؤقته ومن
الاخوه جاءت القوه
الطبيب في الاصل تعني الخبير يقول علقمه
الفحل فان تسالوني بالنساء فانني
بصير بادواء النساء طبيب
والطب هو الخبير الماهر ايضا قال عن تراه
ان تغدفي دوني القناع فانني طب باخذ
الفارس المستلئم
وعندما وجدوا معاليه الامراض بارعا ماهرا
سموه طبيبا
العاطل الذى ليس بيده عملها الاصل ان
القدماء كانوا يقولون عن المراه التي ليس
لديها اساور انها عاطل
العيان هو المريض الاصل ان عينا اصابته
بمرض فمن الحين التي زعموها اصابته جاءت
كلمه العين
المشوار هو مسير بغرض التنزه او قضاء
مصلحه في القديم كان الرجل يثور الذهب به
قبل شرائها اي شيء بها جيئه وذهابا واصبح
مكان عرض الدواب يسمى المشوار
ويرى المرحوم يوسف الزعبلاوي اللغوي
السوري اننا يجب المطلق على منصه عرض
الازياء اسم المشوار
[موسيقى]
قال يحيى بن خالد الحسد عدو مهيا لا
يدركوا
ولا ينال ساره الا بالمائه
قال عبد الملك بن مروان الحجاج بن يوسف
الثقفي انه ليس من احد الا وهو يعرف عيب
نفسه
بنفسه قال اعفني يا امير المؤمنين قال بل
تفعل قال ان جوج حسود حقود
فقال عبد الملك ما في الشيطان شيء شرم ما
ذكرت
وقال الاحنف بن قيس التميمي
الملول ليس له وفاء والكذاب ليست له حينه
والحشود ليست له راحه والبخيل ليست له
مروءه ولا يسود سيئ الخلق
[موسيقى]
نعم
عند جهينه الخبر اليقين
فمن هو هذا الجهني و ناقصه هذا الخبر
كان الحسين قاتلا فاتكا وقد هام على وجهه
يقطع الطريق فيقتل من يقدر على قتله ويسلب
مساع
ولقيه الا خمس الجهميه وكان فاتك مثله
وتعهد ان لا يقدر اي منهما بالاخر وان
يصطحبها في قطع الطريق وسلم الناس
علم الصديقان للفاتيكان يوما بان رجل
انصرف من عند الامير ب هدايا وجوائز
فترصد اه حتى وجد اه مستظلا في ظل شجره
فاتياه فدعاهما الى الطعام فاكل معه شربه
ثمان الجهاني ذهب لبعض حاجته عندما رجع
وجد صاحبه الحصين وسيفه بيده يقطر دما
ووجد الرجل الذي ضيف هما قتيلا يتشحط في
دمه سلام الجهني صاحبه الحصين على فعلته
فقال الحسين ع عدم طعامنا والله ما خرجنا
الا لمثل هذا
فاظهر الجهني الرضا وقعدوا كل مع الحصين
ولكنه اثر كان صاحبه الحصين غادر لا عهد
له
واقتنص منه غفله فعل اه بالسيف وقتل
وسلب الجهني المتاكله
في سبيله وتابعنا اللصوصيه
افتقد اهل الحصين ابنهم ولعل هم فرحوا
بغيابه وغياب اخطائه ولكن اخذه ظلت تركب
الاسواق وتسال الناس ان كانوا راوا اخاها
وصادف ان سمعها الجهني في بعض الاسواق
فمضى عنها وهو يقول
تساءل عن اخيها كل ركب وعند جهينه الخبر
اليقين
وذهبت مثلا عند جهينه الخبر اليقين
التصحيف ان يضع المرء خائن بدل الحال او
شيء من بدل السين وقد كثر هذا في القديم
عندما كان المؤلف يوضع نسخه كتابه عند
الوراق وياخذ النساخ بنسخه فلا ينسخ عن
الاصل وناسخ ينسخ عن نسخه زميله وتمتلك
النسخ بالاغلاق قال ابو احمد العسكري
صاروا اليوم يصفون اكثر مما يصححون
الزعتر المعروف هو عند القدماء الساتر
بالصين فلماذا قال بعضهم الصادر بالصاد
صادف ان كتب بعضهم رقعه ينصح الوهمي فيها
بتناول الساتر لعلاج السعال
ولم تكن الكتابه منقطه انذاك فقرا الوالي
الشعير بدل الساعه وك هذا الت قال واقعه
ومن يومها كتب
الف معمر بن المثنى كتبا كثيره بينها كتاب
ما تلحن فيه العوام وقد قيل انه اخطا في
كتاب من كتبه مائتي خطا ف اذا عرفنا ان
كتبه كانت من مصادر المعاجم الكبرى التي
الفت بعد وفاته فلا يعود غريبا ما نجده في
المعاجم من اخطاء
المسجد معروف واما المسجد بالفتح فهو
العضو الذي يسجد مع الانسان وهي اعضاء
سبعه اليدان والركبتان والقدمان هذه السته
والوضع السابع هو الجبهه واما المسجد فهو
الحصير الصغير والجمع للمسجد والمسجد
والمسجد مساجد
ام
[موسيقى]
العاميه غض الطرف
وهي من العطش والعمل اي الرؤيه ال غائمه
وقالوا للمتعامل عن الامر انه م تغاضت
ونقول في العاميه انه
او
عشان وعلشان اصلهم الفصيح على شان اي من
اجل
فوازير مصر حزازير في الاردن والفصيح
الاحاديه غير ان الحضور مشتقه من الفعل
الفصيح حذر بمعنى حدث
في العمليه الامر يبسط اي يفرح وفي الفصحى
هو يبسط يجعل اسارير الوجه مبسطه فالاولى
ان نقول هذا الامر يبسطني
قال ابن سيده الاندلسي البساطه هي العين
وعلى هذا الفعل
ونسب فصيح ونقول في الفصحى بصيص من النور
اي شعار
كانت الولايات العثمانيه تسمى سناجق
بيروت
واستندت بالتركيه الرايه
[موسيقى]
الجرم بالكسره و الجسم السماوي من كوكبا
والشمس
والجرم بالضمه الجريمه
الحيره التحرير والحيره بالكسر عاصمه
النعمان وقد زحفت عليها في العراق اليوم
الكوفه والنجف
نقول دار في خالده لا في خله ونقول اخلد
للنوم
الطرف الجانب والطرف بالسكون العين ونحن
نغض الطرف انخفض اعيننا فلان حدد تحديدا
هذا عندما تمر بجانبنا فتاه مثلا ومجازا
نحن نغض الطرف عن اخطاء ابناءنا نريدهم ان
يجربوا الحياه ويبني شخصياتهم ويتعلم من
اخطائهم
لا نقول طوال النهار وطوال اشخاصا فارع
القامه بل نقول طوال النهار
عرض البحر وسطه وكنا عرض الحائط وعرض
والمستطيل جانبه الاقصر وعرض الرجل شرفه
الاعقد تقلده المراه والعقد عشره سنوات او
عقد ايجار المنزل
العقار الدواء والعقار البيت ولماذا نقول
للدواء قرارا بشده على القاء ننظر الى
الجمع فهو عقاقير وفيها قا فان اذن فالاصل
مشدده والدواء هو عقد
العنان السحابه وعنان السماء سحابها وال
عن ان بالكسر يقود الفرس
نقول هو لا يتزحزح قيد شعره عن موقفه اي
مقدار شعره ونقول هو مقبل بقيد من حديد
القيد المقبل دار والقيم ما يغلبه المعصم
الغد النحيل وضده السنين نقول فلان لا
يميز بين الغث والسمين
الرصاصه تنفذ في الجسم والسلع تنفذ من
السوق
البطل المتصل مكلل بالغار اي ان على راسه
اكليلا من اغصان شجر الغار ولا نقول ان
المعتدي مكلل بالعار فلا اكليل هنا نقول
هو مجله بالامر
ام
[موسيقى]
بضع في اللغه تعني قطعه ومن هنا مبضع
الجراح
فانقطعت من لحم الخروف قطعه فهي بضعه وال
بضعه في الارقام تؤنث مع المذكر وتذكر مع
المؤنث نقول يضع مخاطر وبضعه اقلام
نقول ونعمل المذكر وبؤسا ونعمه للمؤلف
نقول مثلا يصح ان الزميلي بالاستقاله فبئس
الراي وبؤسه نصيحه فان كنت متحمسا
للاستقاله فانا اقول لاعمار الراي ونعمه
نصيحه وتجوز ونعمه للمؤنث ايضا
التعبير مدن الصفيح درج بالعربيه زمنا
ولكن الظاهره لم تقتصر على تلك البيوت
التي لها اسقف من صحيح والتي تنتشر عند
اطراف المدن الكبرى فهناك احياء مكتوبه
داخل المدن تكاد تنعدم فيها الخدمات ويبدي
الناس فيها البيوت بعضها فوق بعض عشوائيا
وبنا صحيح وجاءت كلمه العشوائيات لتمثل
المعنى تمثيلا اشمل
[موسيقى]
من حكمه المرء ان يحسن خطاب الملوك
والامراء ومن ذكائه ان يجيد اقتناص الفرصه
السانحه
قدم رجل من اهل الشام على ابي جعفر
المنصور
وتكلم معه كلاما حسنا فقال له ابو جعفر
حاجتك فقال يبقيك الله يا امير المؤمنين
قال ابو جعفر حاجتك فانه ليس كل ساعه يمكن
كهذا فقال الشامي
والله لا اس تقصر عمرك ولا اخاف بخلق ولا
اغتنم مالك وان سؤالك لشرف وان عطاؤك زين
لامرئ
بذل وجهه اليك نقص ولا شيء فقال ابوجعفر
يا ربيع لا ينصرف من مقامه الا بمائه الف
درهم ف حملت معها
يقولون الرؤيه ك اجنحه الطير اذا قصه وقعت
وتعبير الرؤيا يختلف باختلاف الراي
كان محمد ابن سيرين من ائمه التابعين وكان
مشهورا بتعبير الرؤيه وينسب اليه في هذا
المضمار كتاب المشهور جاء الى محمد بن
سيرين في حلقته بالمسجد رجل فقال رايت في
المنام اني ا رفع الاذان فما تاويل ذلك
قال له ان شاء الله وبعد ايام جاءه رجل
اخر وقال رايت في المنام اني ا رفع الاذان
ف اش اح ابن سيرين بوجهه وقال له ابحاث
احلام انصر في هذا فانصرف الرجل فتعجب
تلامذته من اختلاف التاويل رغم اتفاق ال
من امين فقال لهم نظرت في وجه الاول
وتمثلت في ذهن قوله تعالى واذن في الناس
بالحج ياتوك رجالا وعلى كل ضامر
ونظرت في وجه الثاني هو ردت على ذهن الايه
ثم اذن مؤذن ايتها العير انكم لسارقون
وبعد عده تسامع الناس بان الاول حج فعلا
فاما الثاني فقد سبق
[موسيقى]
ام
كنا قد ساهم في توتر عن ابرز حدث لغوي او
ثقافي او ادبي شهده العالم العربي خلال
المائه سنه الماضيه وقد وصلتنا منكم
الكثير من المشاركات نستعرض بعضها جابر
الجلاب قال انه مهرجان المربد الثقافي
وادان قالت هو برنامج فصاحه وهذه المشاركه
منهم ويقول هذه اه المجله مجله الرساله
لرئيسها الابيب الزيات رحمه الله
وليد السويد كان له راي اخر فقال هو الحدث
العلمي للعلوم والتكنولوجيا والتطبيق نجوم
العلوم
ومشاركه من عبد الرحمن قال الاجابه صعبه
لكن التحول الابرز كان عن طريق والشهر
المهجر بدايه القرن العشرين كذلك ترجمات
وتباع المهجر التي اسست لدور اتجاه هذه
الكتابه النثريه العربيه
الحديثه
وهناك مشاركه من اساس يقول او تقول
المعارك الادبيه في مصر بين عمالقه الادب
هي الحدث الابرز
والمشاركه الاخيره من محمد يحيى الذي قال
حصول نجيب محفوظ على جائزه نوبل
[موسيقى]
على رفوف المكتبات العربيه تستلقي سير
عظيمه لاشخاص
عن سعيد الافغان احدثكم الكشميري الذي حمل
لواء اللغه العربيه
توفيت امه العربيه الدمشقيه و عمره ثلاث
سنوات فنشا الطفل في حضن والده الكشميري
الذي لا يكاد يحسن العربيه ومع ذلك اصبح
سعيد الافغان حامل اللواء العربيه واستاذ
اساس يدها كما يصفه تلميذه مازن المبارك
كان الطفل سعيد يمسك مع ابيه في حي
البزوري المحاذي الجامع الاموي بدمشق
فكان يتخذ من صاحب الجامع طريقا في ذهابه
وايابه
وفي حلقات الدرس بالجامع الاموي وفي
الكتائب المنتشره في الاحياء المجاوره
استقى سعيد الافغانيه علمه وغرامه باللغه
العربيه واكتسبت صديقا مره الشيخ علي
الطنطاوي الذي سيصبح عديله كان ذلك زمن
التتريك فقد ورد سعيد الافغاني عام الف
وتسعمائه وتسعه ولكن مدرسته الرسميه
الاولى كانت تحرص على اللغه العربيه فاذن
لدى تلميذ فقال الكلمه المعهوده افندم
زجره المعلم واوجب عليه ان يقول ل بهيك لم
يد ال الافغان درجه الماجستير ولا الدكتور
اه فقد جهد فيهما ومع ذلك اصبح استاذ كرسي
ثم عميدا للاداء في الجامعه السوريه
كان هذا في زمن يقدر قيمه العلم للشهادات
وكان الافغانيه عضوا في مجامع دمشق
والقاهره وبغداد كان سعيد الافغاني انحا
نحات بلاد الشام وكان شديدا على طلبته لا
يقبل التوسط يقول تلميذه مازن المبارك انه
نقال في صحيفه يحمل صاحبه على الافغان
حمله شديده فتعجب من الامر
الاستاذه لا يظهر في المقال اي سبب لمثل
هذا العداء فقال الاستاذ بل هناك سبب لقد
ارسلت كاتب المقال ثلاث مرات
ومن طريف ما كان يروى طلبه جامعه دمشق عن
سعيد الافغاني انهم عندما كانوا يطالعون
لوائح الناجحين
المعلقه على الجدار في ختام السنه
الدراسيه كانوا كثيرا ما يعود لائحه
الاستاذ سعيد في ماده النحو والصرف
وعليها تحت كلمه الناجحون كلمتان فقط لا
احد
كان سعيد الافغان منقطعا الى العلم
توفي سعيد الافغاني في جده عام سبعه
وتسعين
وهو يزور وحيدته المتزوجه هناك ودفن في
مكه المكرمه
رحم الله سعيد الافغاني كان زاهدا في
الشهادات مقدرا العلم حريصا عليه وكان
انحا نحات بلاد الشام
[موسيقى]
على عطشى نقوم الى السباق
جيبات الاعتراف شواهد بين جلق والعراق لما
البطش تفهمها السواق ولم يكن سيئا وديه
شهاب السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
نعم